[Música]
ha llegado finalmente
a finales de diciembre de 2022 nuestro
equipo recibió información sobre la
existencia de una empresa de actividades
sospechosas llamada sanitics gabón esta
empresa tenía una página en Facebook y
un sitio web y parecía dedicarse a la
fabricación de paneles solares sin
embargo ofrecía inversiones muy
productivas y una rentabilidad
completamente excepcional el principio
era este los inversionistas alquilaban
un generador solar y la energía generada
era vendida automáticamente por el
sistema sanedix y monetizada al ser
convertida en Franco cefa que llegaban a
la cuenta bancaria del cliente en
internet había numerosos vídeos que
explicaban el funcionamiento de este
negocio por cada generador por ejemplo
un pvecero da un ingreso diario de 100
Francos un pv1 da 400 un 500 un pv3 dan
5000 un 4 da 20.000 un pv5 da 45.000
amigos les aseguro que se ganen todos
los niveles
a nuestro observador
le pareció demasiado bueno para ser
verdad y se puso en contacto con nuestra
redacción para hablarnos del tema
un familiar me envió el enlace y me
pidió que hiciera parte de la comunidad
pensé Bueno antes de hacerlo de qué se
trata exactamente entonces empecé
Buscando el nombre son erics encontré la
página oficial de la empresa Noté que
gabón no figuraba entre sus filiales Así
que escribí un tuit diciendo son erics
está instalando en gabón pidiéndole a la
gente que invierta Pero sabemos que todo
esto es falso
la estrategia de nuestro observador
funcionó ya que la verdadera empresa
zannedix publicó un comunicado el 28 de
diciembre en el cual explicó que no
tenía filiales en África y afirmó que
nunca pediría dinero ni información
personal pero esto no impidió que la
página de Facebook de saneddix gabón
siguiera promo sus actividades y no todo
se hacía de manera virtual
en cuanto a las comunicaciones fueron
persuasivos Porque Se tomaron fotos con
varias autoridades para mostrar el
carácter legal de esta empresa
recorrieron las provincias fueron a
entregarle donaciones a la gente en Mi
humilde opinión
engañaron a las autoridades no paraban
de decir miren somos una empresa de
verdad legalmente constituida hagan
parte de la compañía Para hacerse ricos
ese era el eslogan que se vendía en
efecto saneds gabón era una empresa real
que estaba registrada legalmente ante
las autoridades japonesas desde el 10 de
noviembre del 2022 incluso tenía un
documento oficial gracias a este
registro las autoridades nos confirmaron
la autenticidad de este documento
precisando a la vez que la empresa no
tenía permitido proponerle a sus
clientes que invirtieran y sus
actividades hablamos con una de las
víctimas que aceptó contarnos lo
sucedido con la condición de mantenerse
en el anonimato
lo que me tranquilizó para invertir en
son edits fue que la sede era real
Cuando visité las oficinas todos los
asistentes daban conferencia los sábados
cuando una empresa se instala y tiene
una sede significa que las autoridades
se encargaron de verificar el negocio y
sus seriedad
en cuanto al dinero que perdimos es un
total de 430 mil Francos unos 650 euros
es un claro ejemplo de un esquema ponzi
es decir un fraude en el que los
intereses del dinero de los
inversionistas son pagados
principalmente con el dinero que aportan
los nuevos clientes este sistema colapsa
cuando ya no hay nuevos inversionistas
para sane todo terminó la noche del 10
de enero la empresa eliminó su página de
Facebook y los principales
administradores desaparecieron al no
poder retirar su dinero
víctimas decidieron acudir a las
oficinas de sanedix en la capital
gabonesa
no se sabe exactamente cuántas personas
fueron estafadas zane edix gabón Afirma
tener 100.000 integrantes una cifra
probablemente muy exagerada en los
grupos de WhatsApp creados por sanitics
gabón para estar en contacto con los
inversionistas contamos casi 1000
personas y varios centenares seguían su
página de Facebook no es la primera vez
que un caso de este tipo ocurren gabón
en el verano del 2022 la empresa jds
technologies estafó a miles de jaboneses
utilizando este mismo método nuestro
observador
y da algunos consejos para evitar caer
en estafas el consejo básico es estar
alerta cuestionar la fuente y
preguntarse de dónde procede esta
información porque si no viene de la
prensa ni de las autoridades es que hay
un problema y también como consejo está
el tema de la rentabilidad de las
bonificaciones realmente hay que
desconfiar de donde a uno le piden
invertir por ejemplo mil Francos para
ganar 2000 Francos en menos de 24 horas
es preocupante ver cómo se multiplican
este tipo de iniciativas en gabón por
eso es necesario que las autoridades se
ocupen del problema que busquen
soluciones y prevean mecanismos de
control y vigilancia para las empresas
que en realidad son creadas por
estafadores
después de ser contactados por nuestro
equipo el Ministerio de economía de
gabón publicó un comunicado confirmó que
shanedix no tenía un acuerdo debidamente
establecido para realizar actividades
bancarias e invitó a las víctimas a
denunciar
[Música]
continuaremos haciendo seguimiento a
este caso con nuestros observadores es
todo por esta semana Recuerden que
ustedes pueden comunicarse con nuestra
redacción para informarnos sobre
diferentes hechos que ocurren en sus
países en sus pantallas aparecen los
medios para entrar en contacto con
nuestro equipo Hasta pronto